[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
If awesome developer
updates are your thing,
make sure to subscribe.
We believe that AI
technologies are
likely to be overwhelmingly
useful and beneficial
for humanity.
But part of being a responsible
steward of any new technology
is thinking through
potential challenges
and how to best address
any associated risks.
So we published a technical
paper, "Concrete Problems
in AI Safety," which was a
collaboration among scientists
at Google, OpenAI,
Stanford, and UC Berkeley.
The post has an overview
and a link to the paper.
And if that paper
isn't enough, check out
this list of our
research being presented
at the 2016 International
Conference on Machine Learning.
With Chrome 52, we're
introducing the ability
to make storage persistent.
For more details and some
code, check out the post.
Also in Chrome 52, WebRTC uses
a much more efficient and secure
algorithm for certificate
generation, ECDSA.
And RTC certificates can now
be stored with indexed DB.
There's a post with details
and code on this too.
Building an
authentication system
is, well, bothersome
to say the least.
However, with Firebase
Authentication,
you can outsource the
entire thing to Firebase
so that you can
concentrate on building
great features for your app.
Visit the post for
details and examples.
OK, so if you're
watching this, you're
probably already an
amazing developer.
But perhaps you have a friend
who has a great idea for an app
but doesn't know where
to start and keeps
bugging you to do it for them.
Enter the Android
Basics Nanodegree.
This series of
courses and services
teaches your friend how to
build simple Android apps,
even if they have little or
no programming experience.
Also in the Getting
Started category,
we're excited to announce
Google Cloud Platform education
grants for computer science
faculty and students.
Faculty in the US who teach
courses in computer science
or related subjects can apply
for free credits for students
to use across the full
complement of Google Cloud
Platform tools.
And they can be used
anytime during the 2016
to 2017 academic year.
Mobirix saw about a 15% uplift
in the number of paying users
and about a 43% increase in
average revenue per paying user
after implementing a
hybrid monetization
model of in-app payments and
ads for its apps on Beehive.
Learn more from the
post linked below.
Adults are 30% more likely to
prefer online video platforms
over TV when given a choice
where to watch video content.
This and other insights are
now available in a study
from comScore,
commissioned by Google
and available at the link below.
Check it out for six things
to keep in mind as you
develop your 2017 media plan.
Have I mentioned recently
that you should subscribe
to this channel
so you don't miss
any of the developer
awesomeness happening at Google?
I have?
OK, cool.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]